all of duty ghosts whips out their third
DLC pack called invasion this purchase
dishes out for unique multiplayer maps
and the third episode to the side story
game mode extinction since this episode
3 called awakening is spoiler heavy I
ain't gonna touch it so let's go back
and take a quick look at these new
multiplayer maps first on the list we're
digging in Egypt the maps called Pharaoh
and it doesn't just bring you sand but a
complex multi-leveled map with plenty of
nooks and crannies to pop out from the
layout is great with plenty of fun
surprises to utilize such as vases
filled with flesh-eating scarabs no no a
collapsing monument to smash you and/or
your enemies and if you manage to switch
three torches that are scattered across
the map a hidden door opens up revealing
a secret treasure care package to
dashboard but as the great acabar once
said first a truck grab the goods and
GTFO because if there's just the
slightest hesitation you're [ __ ]
even better if you feel like being a
backstabbing piece of little stand in
the doorway sorry fellas end of the line
you've served your country wet oh well I
guess I had that coming and if you
manage to get the maps field order the
Egyptian god Anubis will rise and will
give you a friendly pat on the back
blessing you with every single Kirk in
the game for four lives out of the maps
furrows easily the most popular with
whoa whoa doc fight next up fiesta
departed brings us to Mexico for the day
of the day another map that really
shines in its attention to detail party
float in the middle plays music a party
hearse for the party graveyard and party
Jesus but where the party really lies is
in the festive field order reward death
mariachi accomplished this field order
and really start the party with a Kimbo
44 magnums and get all jacked up on
juggernaut health and speed perks all
enemies become visible and when you kill
a player squad mates ponds giving you up
to two mates at a time to help you
spread the love for all to enjoy or hate
this maps called mutiny where you battle
the dots of a pirate hideout or take the
fight to the deck of a pirate ship match
the maps tight corners and close
encounters with speed and stealth perks
so you can better your chance on getting
the maps to field order rewards which
are cannon barrage where you call an
offshore pirate ship to hammer down on
your foes or you can get pirate ghosts
because ghosts these guys follow your
round so you can take clowns down the
last map of the bunch brings back the
fan faithful Vella first seen in modern
warfare 2 this classic medium sized map
gets a rejuvenated environment with
pretty details and more chickens it's a
fairly big map if there's no escaping
those close quarter showdowns and
apparently there's no escaping the fun
slide and that's it I mean plus teesside
episode that's about it
now the real question is is this worth
15 buckaroo knees personally come on
we'll undecided but hey leave your
answer in the comments and thanks for
watching see you next time